everything's weird nothing's weird this
is Dori of me discovering my biological
father if you want to see part one click
here I kind of pointed out
[Music]
my name is Sam this is my mom Lauren and
then this is my sperm donor genetic
father Brian the whole thing was funny
because I was the one who found Brian
and was doing this whole huge surge
after at all now my brother was the
person who was going to more events and
everything because he lived in New York
Brian had gotten my brother and fiancee
take it to the US Open yes who else is
gonna be at the US Open my mom so we
found out they're gonna be there on the
same day and I was like okay spill the
beans like just say everything tell her
everything like they're gonna meet the
Lauren was kind of caught off guard cuz
her kids didn't tell her til the last
minute that they were attending the
tournament that I would be there so they
call her that day of the US Open and say
that oak turns out we have met the donor
you know we're actually going to the US
Open tonight and he's gonna be there I
knew I was gonna get in trouble for the
text that I responded no to in the same
day my mom found out who the donor was
and that she was actually going to be
meeting him at first I was angry just
because they surprised me I was
overwhelmed you're always concerned when
new people enter your kids lives because
the holidays are split already three
ways and now are they gonna need to be
split four ways because now there's a
third parent in that moment you start to
overthink it
I'm always feeling a little threatened
if this DNA donor dad you know he's
really calling he lives in New York and
my son lives in New York and they can go
and do things that are really fun and
it's different and it just was probably
the the least desirable environment that
one could be in to ingest news like that
we met up at the US Open at one of the
breaks and the sets I couldn't stop
staring at him because I saw physical
characteristics of my kids
second I looked at him so she told me
that when she saw Brian she saw those
are Sam's eyes kind of female version
nose mouth and she has your hands since
then yes I have looked at my hands and I
have a pinkie that sticks out but then
what was great is that I was able to get
together at another branch that was
really nice to get to meet her and
really got to know each other because it
was just the two of us and so we had
talked for hours so very quickly I
became very comfortable with him I feel
like we have a connection a bond if we
become friends which i think is great I
mean we're both single and we both date
and it's really cool to have another you
know guy friend after this brunch that
you know Brian was super excited he said
that they were BFFs the day after the US
Open I told my close girlfriend she said
oh my god that's great more to love and
I looked at her like she was crazy and
said are you can because I was still
threatened then a few days later I said
you're right that's a good way to look
at it more to love the whole thing was
just cool bizarre I don't know what you
want to call it that our two genetic
sources are now friends I guess we're
still navigating like what to call each
other and everything we're navigating
social media even like what is where I
want to be called I mean we just call
Brian Brian I just prefer to be called
Brian and then like if I talk to friends
and I'm the donor usually donor
biological father I reserve dad for my
dad I mean for 25 years this was a
secret we just didn't tell anyone the
kids didn't even know and now I'm very
open to say oh my kid's donor you know
I've actually just called CB 186 that
first moment that I met you at the US
Open immediately you started talking to
me about stem cell and I was trying to
keep up with you one of the big
questions is does that DNA from somebody
else incorporate into your genome to
no one's really quite been able to
answer that question it's been you know
eight years since I did my first time
cell treatment there's probably not a
sample of my sperm still left in the
freezer okay well there's there's none
for sale anyway I called over there to
see if they had one dose left and they
don't I would like to see if the HLA
expression for me has changed before and
after the stem-cell treatment so that
would give you some indication of
whether the DNA from the stem cells
incorporates into your own DNA or not so
is there any way you can find out if
your DNA has changed based on comparing
it to mine no not really because you
have DNA from two separate people so it
could just be from Lauren's tenth
contribution to your DNA code what if
they compared the Y chromosome okay so
if you only compare the Y chromosome
yeah so that I suppose they might be
able to do that yeah that's an
interesting idea
she's smart I wonder where she gets it
all from which one one of the reasons
why we chose Brian were for you know
just some of the things that we could
pick up on the application that are
similar to her father what we're trying
to find someone who had some commonality
now after meeting Brian I can kind of
piece together my nature versus nurture
a little bit more and see actually how
much nurture I've gotten from my dad to
make me me and then maybe just some
nature aspects that have come from Brian
and then obviously my mom too and I
think I'm just this combo of all three
sources in my opinion best to always
tell the truth and to be open I would
just suggest that anyone who finds
themselves in a similar situation just
try to embrace the positive don't be so
threatened by it I think this has just
been a great way to expand our family
for any other kid or young adult going
through this I would tell
you know no one's replacing your parents
no one's replacing anyone but it's it's
just how you happen to be here and you
wouldn't exist otherwise like you
literally wouldn't be here you wouldn't
be the person you are without all of
this you know it it makes you unique in
this day and age we're gonna find out
anyway so you might as well be up front
and tell us you know there there are a
lot of surprises in life this is a good
one so do you have any advice for other
sperm donors who are in the same
situation I would just recommend that if
they're comfortable that they should
release the information cuz I mean I
always said I think it's been a really
positive experience for me I told the
sperm bank that they could release my
information but they said I was the
first person that had ever contacted
them about that so I said well maybe
it'll change now that more people are
doing this online DNA analysis I sent in
my ancestry DNA and my 23andme
and then there's kids out there that I
don't really know about or until maybe
at some point they'll match up on this
ancestry DNA or 23andme I think that
every kid has a right to know where they
come from I think there are plenty of
half-siblings out there who don't
realize they're half siblings so parents
don't tell their kids and their kids get
DNA tests they can find out by matching
with other half siblings
so then ancestry DNA emailed me that
there were updates I go to check out DNA
relatives there's a new one that says
close family to first cousin range he's
the same age as my brother I kind of put
two and two together I'm like okay this
could be the first half sibling match
and I said what
[Music]